this major shopping street in kerala's
allapura district is unusually deserted
for this time of year
the state is in the middle of onam its
biggest festival and shopping season
bindu krishna is weaving a marigold
garland used for onam decoration
after months of closure vendors like her
were finally allowed to set up shop but
celebrations have been muted and demand
has been slow because of rising covet 19
infections across the state
the government should decide sometimes
allow us to open sometimes they want us
to close what will poor people like us
too if they ask us to shut shop after
onam will be in great trouble
once praised for controlling the
pandemic kerala has now become the kobit
19 hotspot in india
the local government has eased
restrictions for the festival
and state police have been deployed to
enforce mass mandates and prevent
crowding
there are rules requiring shoppers to
either get a negative pcr test or show
proof of vaccination
but shopkeepers say these are hard to
implement and are affecting business
during peak season
business has become really difficult
since the pandemic started we have been
forced to shut our shops even when the
markets opened the police comes in and
we have to request them to let us run
our shop so we can make some money
with a high number of infections experts
say kerala and india's north east are
still in second wave of the pandemic
which could lead to a surge in other
states
roughly nine percent of all indians have
been vaccinated across the country
unless we are seeing
above 60 percent of the population
vaccinated and preferably up to 80
everywhere we cannot really say that
india is safe
because if there are large pockets of
vaccinated population in different parts
of india
the
i mean the pandemic would actually flare
up there or new variants could arrive
arise there
but despite a high vaccination rate
kerala's positivity rate is above 15
prompting the central government to give
more than 30 million dollars to
strengthen its health services pavni
mithal al-jazeera new delhi